- We are here with Oprah Winfrey.
- I'm doing drew.
I'm doing Drew right now.
- Hi Gayle.
- Can you hear Drew?
Yeah, she's saying hi,
she's saying hi Gayle.
- Hello.
- I just wanna say
I think the three of
us should get together.
You know, I think that
would be so much fun.
- Yes, when this pandemic is over,
let's make sure that happens Drew.
- All right Gayle I'll talk to you later.
(all laugh)
(audience applauds)
- You know we all, I
think, thrive in this world
through friendship.
A lot of children and marriages,
the friends were there at the beginning.
They'll be there till the end.
They're these sort of
lifelong relationships.
It's different than
blood family it's choice
but it feels as intimate and loyal.
And your friendship with
Gayle has been something that,
we all aspired to
because we want that kind
of friendship in our life.
And by the way, you know have Oprah Daily
which I happened to mention to Gayle
that I thought that the Oprah Daily,
The Daily word is so brilliant.
- Well, thank you. Thank you.
I actually came up with that
because I wanted it to be,
what I realized is that
the Oprah Show was a habit.
Just like the Drew Barrymore Show.
People are creating a habit around that.
And that's what you want.
That's your core viewer.
That's who you're speaking to every day.
And the idea of having a
daily inspiration point,
a daily quote, a daily something
that you can rely on to
give you just a little lift.
You know, my whole goal
throughout my life,
even before I could articulate it
is how do you bring a
light into people's lives?
How do you let them see
the best of themselves?
How do you allow them to grow
into becoming more of who they are?
Which is what every one of us
is actually aspiring to do.
Whether you can articulate
that for yourself or not.
You just wanna become more, more solid.
You wanna have the ability
to have the fullest expression
of yourself as a human being.
And you do that by habits, by rituals
by creating a space where
you can give back to yourself
in a way that allows you to flourish.
So we are growing it into
what I know will be in the future
is a daily spot of
inspiration for everybody.
So thank you for mentioning that.
- We need you on The Daily.
I listened to your Sirius XM channel
through both my pregnancies
and it was my daily North star.
It was my daily fix.
- Well, thank you for that.
- It's true.
I'll never forget the
story you told about Gayle
getting the water for the traffic cop
and how that moment was her being
such an and good parent to her son
because she was showing him
the kind of person to be
and that gave me hope,
because I felt so lost.
Like what blueprint do I have
to pull on to become a parent?
I was scared out of my mind.
And I thought hearing that story,
if I can be an example to my kids,
maybe I don't have to draw
from my past or even fight it.
I can try to be myself.
And that can give me
hope to be a good parent.
That story literally changed my life.
So thank you for that.
- Well, you know, Gayle is to date
and she always says,
"Well, all parents do that.
I say "No they don't."
Gayle is to date the best
model parent I have ever seen.
I've never seen anybody
who was more engaged,
more respectful of her children.
And when she first had kids,
because we were best friends
and met in a television
station in Baltimore.
And once she married and
had kids, I thought, well
there's gonna be distance
in our relationship.
'Cause she's not gonna have time
to devote to our friendship.
And that did not happen.
But what did happen every time
she was on the phone with me
and one of her children entered
the room, she would stop.
She would put the phone down.
Even if she didn't put the phone down
they would be acknowledged.
She was present there for them.
She would say, "Mommy's on
the phone now with Aunty O
and morning bear." She calls Kirby bear.
There was an acknowledgement,
and what I would have
to say over the years,
of mutual respect.
And I know we're gonna be talking later
about the subject of what happened to you.
But one of the things that
Dr. Perry says in this book
is that when children
grow up and they realize
that they are not getting
the respect that they deserve
from their parents,
it changes who they are.
What's your kids want,
and this is actually to have everybody,
they wanna know that you're
here, that you see me
that you see me and you hear me,
and that I mattered to you.
And that is true for everybody
else in your life too.
- We are here with Oprah Winfrey.
- I'm doing Drew.
I'm doing drew right now.
- Hi Gayle.
- Oh hi Gayle.
- Can you hear Drew?
- Yeah, she's saying hi,
she's saying hi, Gayle.
- Hello.
- I just wanna say
I think the three of
us should get together.
You know, I think that
would be so much fun.
- Yes, when this pandemic is over,
let's make sure that happens Drew.
All right, Gayle, I'll talk to you later.
(all laugh)
(audience applauds)
- You know we all, I
think, thrive in this world
through friendship.
A lot of children and marriages,
the friends were there at the beginning.
They'll there till the end.
They're these sort of
lifelong relationships.
It's different than
blood family it's choice
but it feels as intimate and loyal.
And your friendship with
Gayle has been something that,
we all aspired to
because we want that kind
of friendship in our life.
And by the way,
you know how Oprah Daily
which I happened to mention to Gayle,
that I thought that the Oprah Daily,
The Daily word it's so brilliant.
- Well, thank you. Thank you.
I actually came up with that because
I wanted it to be,
what I realized is that
the Oprah show was a habit.
Just like the Drew Barrymore show.
People are creating a habit around that.
And that's what you want.
That's your core viewer.
That's who you're speaking to every day.
And the idea of having a
daily inspiration point,
a daily quote, a daily something
that you can rely on to
give you just a little lift.
You know, my whole goal
throughout my life,
even before I could articulate it
is how do you bring a
light into people's lives?
How do you let them see
the best of themselves?
How do you allow them to grow
into becoming more of who they are,
which is what every one of us
is actually aspiring to do.
Whether you can articulate
that for yourself or not.
You just wanna become more, more solid.
You wanna have the ability to
have the fullest expression
of yourself as a human being.
And you do that by habits, by rituals,
by creating a space where
you can give back to yourself
in a way that allows you to flourish.
So we are growing it into
what I know will be in the future
is a daily spot of
inspiration for everybody.
So thank you for mentioning that.
- We need you on The Daily.
I listened to your Sirius XM channel
through both my pregnancies
and it was my daily North star.
It was my daily fix.
- Well, thank you for that.
- It's true.
I'll never forget the
story you told about Gayle
getting the water for the traffic cop
and how that moment was
her being such an important
and good parent to her son
because she was showing him
the kind of person to be
and that gave me hope,
because I felt so lost.
Like what blueprint do I have
to pull on to become a parent?
I was scared out of my mind.
And I thought hearing that story
if I can be an example to my kids
maybe I don't have to draw
from my past or even fight it.
I can try to be myself.
And that can give me
hope to be a good parent.
That story literally changed my life.
So thank you for that.
- Well, you know, Gayle is to date
and she always says, "Well,
all parents do that."
I say, "No they don't."
Gayle is to date the best
model parent I have seen.
I've never seen anybody
who was more engaged,
more respectful of her children.
And when she first had kids,
because we were best friends
and met at a television
station in Baltimore.
And when she married and
had kids, I thought, well
there's gonna be distance
in our relationship
'cause she's not gonna have time
to devote to our friendship.
And that did not happen.
But what did happen every time
she was on the phone with me
and one of her children entered
the room, she would stop.
She would put the phone down.
Even if she couldn't put the phone down
they would be acknowledged.
She was present there for them.
She would say, "Mommy's on
the phone now with Aunty O
and morning bear." She calls Kirby bear.
There was an acknowledgement,
and what I would have
to say over the years,
of mutual respect.
And I know we're gonna be talking later
about the subject of what happened to you.
But one of the things that
Dr. Perry says in this book
is that when children
grow up and they realize
that they are not getting
the respect that they deserve
from their parents,
it changes who they are.
What's your kids want,
and this is actually true of everybody,
they wanna know that you're
here, that you see me,
that you see me and you hear me
and that I matter to you.
And that is true for everybody
else in your life too.
(upbeat music)